this episode is brought to you by gray
block pizza gray block it's a
fantastical choice to make with your
mouth what is your mouth in your hand
doing right now who knows right you do
and they could be doing great block
pizza great block pizza is just a mouth
and hand program and all they're doing
is just shipping Italian food back and
forth between each other great block
pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard in Los
Angeles also in Bend Oregon they have
bronx-born pizza and that's their sister
sister Pie Company so they're teammates
great block and bronx-born and get them
- you hear that guys here then in the
distance that's Brendan Schaub and Brian
Collins and they're next door dude
arguing about something probably you
know one of them s sciatica and one of
them ah you know those who knows
something I mean that's basically kind
of the two of them but um and you can
guess which ones which that's up to you
dude and that's one of the beauties
about America is you get to make your
own choices but if you hear something
loud coming through the walls we share a
wall with the fighter and the kids and
that's Brendan Schaub and Brian Collins
two adults but depends on who you ask
this weekend June 23rd I'll be at Tim
blur Brewing Company and that's in
Bakersfield California next weekend I'll
be in Stark County Illinois the
following weekend I'll be in Oxnard
California then I'll be in China
Shanghai and Shimon and some other place
I'll also be in Raleigh Minneapolis
Chicago Nashville Toronto Appleton and
Buffalo you can get all those tickets at
theof on calm slash tour tou R and I
thank you very much for coming out to
the shows all right today's brought to
you by Ridge wallet Ridge wallet comm
some people carry something in their
pocket and they don't you know what the
[ __ ] it is do I'll tell you what it is
it's a wallet and they keep it in their
back pocket and that's so archaic who
are you huh
who are you due to senior citizen or you
a a pirate or somebody a Neanderthal
because the new thing is that front
pocket carry and that front pocket carry
is basically the ridge wallet Yukie
bring your front pocket so no more
laying in bed at night worrying if a
pickpocket is gonna get you because if a
pickpocket gets you in the front then
something's wrong with you the ridge
wallet go to Ridge wallet calm slash
Theo th EO today's guest is is a
musician and I met him at the
world-famous Comedy Store and this this
will be the first conversation he and I
have ever had here today he's he's a
devout husband and he's a survivor I
think you know he's got one of the most
famous anthems if you will and that is
we're not gonna take it and there's
something just about this man than in
his life I don't think he was gonna take
it and and he's just relentless I'm so
happy to have him in here today and even
though I'm wearing a different shirt
because the intro did it on a different
time but I'm so happy to have this
beautiful Twisted Sister because I have
two Twisted Sisters this beautiful
Twisted Sister mr. Dean Snider
[Music]
yeah let's go uh yes you got that beaver
man yeah
I'm premiering debuting the new look you
know I went I was okay this is what
happened okay so I was just in an
airport lounge had a long layover you
know and I just bored to tears and I'm
just sitting there and I just see this
guy walking with his slave t-shirt on
and I just watch him and I'm watching
them then I'm not being creepy or
anything I'm just sort of just sitting
there you know I don't know way this guy
is a slayer fist I just you know after
about a half hour of physical action I
mean maybe I'm being judgmental maybe
I'm saying but is this I said this is
one of those guys wearing those shirts
right
so I just tweeted casually I said you
know I think it's it's a cool all these
people wearing proposers output wearing
our shirts wearing the metal shirts
ironically they're I were being ironic
about it yeah it's not ironic right it's
our life is our lifestyle we we
literally used to fight to wear these
shirts you know and it was just a
passing I I wasn't trying to make a big
statement was just like I was just bored
and just to eat it blew up thousands and
thousands picked up international news
Dee Snider of lashes out at Kanye West
and and the Kardashians and I didn't
mention anybody by name if you want to
take it personal so anyway recently I'd
you know still and then people fight
they say hey you know what anybody wears
a shirt it's cool I said you know what
there we were in our shirts I'm gonna
wear their shirts like I'm rocking the
Bieber I like that I got me a 84 Madonna
like a virgin to a shirt oh wow I'm
gonna rock that onstage it's a monster
metal festival hello no I mean it's time
you know if they're gonna if they're
gonna exploit our [ __ ] let's go back at
him let's go back at him fight fire with
fire
I like that I want to see you in an
Ariana Grande
I might have to say Oh an Ariana Grande
I'm gonna have to pick a cop although I
get a little critter be careful yeah I'm
a creepy scale oh that's true know what
I mean you know like sixty something
dude wearing like some you know
previously-issued prepubescent Racine
whatever borderline she's yeah she may
be borderline borderline do you feel do
you start to feel like a creepy old dude
you don't seem bro you seem so hip it's
crazy well that's that's pretty cool
thanks Joyce feel it not at all but when
you've got four kids and my daughter's
21 and you know out and about and I'm
good time and I've got grandkids now
yeah you know when they're ones 9 the
girls 9 and you guys got to start
checking yourself and saying okay you
know doesn't matter how you feel you
gotta remember what reality the reality
of what you are be cool that like I
don't wear shirts to say [ __ ] on I mean
I used to be just like a thing you know
[ __ ] you [ __ ] insane
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] [ __ ] it was just
like how many [ __ ] shirts could you have
yeah and now someone says hey it's a
really cool [ __ ] I think you know what
I'm a grandpa I'm not wearing the [ __ ]
right I'm drawing a line there you know
up yours sure but [ __ ] no yeah darn darn
no I'm gonna I like going doorto it's a
little too soft damn where you come from
that day as a word it's a little more
day I got your word yeah where'd you
grow up you talk about as I say saw Theo
at the Comedy Store and just knock me
out I mean I you know just you know you
see a whole bunch of comedians up there
there was some good guys up there but
you came out just attitude everything my
wife my friends were just like wow this
guy's got going on and so just tweeted
about him and do appreciate that was
cool that means a lot came and turns out
you got like a really hot podcast and
everything we're doing great man you
know and look I'm so grateful you came
in and um yeah everything's been going
cool you know I've been figuring it out
but yeah I mean I grew up like I grew up
on metal music you know I grew up like
when they had like the hip the hip
hooray member those magazines you
remember a tour yeah man I do do you
remember I
in those magazines those guys would be
like bloodied and they'd be on tour
they'd show like you know all sweaty and
[ __ ] up or like the the the the
musicians looked like it was grimy it
was it was brother yeah I mean they
weren't gladiators it more looked like
where's my channel like one with the
shoulder pads Italian swears now that
you would never you wouldn't see that
same it was like about drugs and about
partying like it seemed like it had all
these grungy elements it was a different
time for sure you know and now I don't
you know what you know about me you
don't know about me but I never did any
drugs I never drank right I'm sober and
[ __ ] crazy that was a t-shirt I swear
all the time but that's what I have my
brain cells intact I mean I didn't get
you know I mean I had always people you
know they were like they thought life
was like a sprint I'm gonna do it it's a
marathon
ya ain't goin 427 I'm goin 487 you know
and now they're all like I'm living
healthy now too
it's a little late but anyway um so I
have a great observer about what was
going on and it was the decade of
decadence yeah and that's why it's
looked back on so fondly by by young
people know what the shows is it's half
younger people because that era had
something that they're just not find
today you know that finding the music
today not finding the music scene it
doesn't have any glamour to it and I'm
not talk about lipstick only yeah a lot
of lipstick yeah but just didn't have
that sexuality and that I called the
middle finger factor yeah yeah I was
wearing t-shirts it [ __ ] you and just
like that was life like [ __ ] you we have
a good time and people lived like that
yeah it was just a general attitude you
know and it was very conservative time
you had the Reagan era you know you had
that that censorship stuff going out the
PMRC
oh yeah remember my shows downs would
you grow up I grew up down in Louisiana
I grew up it looks like North in New
Orleans probably about an hour so kind
of rural not redneck but rural like I
didn't say nollans he's not home so yeah
I came down yeah but uh yeah but I'm
down with down south we were having I
was arrested for you know for profanity
and abusive language and I've been
cursing like a blue streak so I'm
guessing it's not a problem
it's perfect I'm I got arrested in Texas
and reuleaux Texas I know you know I'm
New York guy street guy wearing
literally in the early days wearing
women's clothing and biker bars I mean
you know I'm like just like fighting
your way to your car every night I mean
I get you know down and dirty and so
suddenly now so we're still those guys
we're still those biker guys you know
and just weird [ __ ]
but now suddenly become famous but we
don't realize the change has happened
hmm
so now we're crossing over into the
mainstream so moms and dads are starting
to bring little Johnny and little Janie
to the show because they like the funny
videos right but we're still like [ __ ]
you yeah so I'm so well I get an
argument a guy Amarillo Texas 1984 and
he's just give me [ __ ] and I just give
them the biggest New York [ __ ] you I can
suck my [ __ ] dick okay that's
like in New York it's not literally like
that's what you want to do is a
statement up that's it that's where
that's what I think of you yeah that's
what I think you well boo mother runs
out with Johnny gets a cop pressed
charges I'm arrested I'm taken in you
know abusive language disorderly conduct
and now so I'll get bailed out we go to
the next town and now the word is
spreading word spread now here's the
word that spread this is this is not
social media this is telephone yeah and
this is on the news Lisa girths was
Sister Dee Snider invited underage girls
onstage to perform oral sex on him like
wow like whoa I was just I was actually
talking to a dude yeah but now it's the
bait you know you're going couldn't
possibly said that to a guy so he
must've been talking to an underage girl
right it couldn't even have happened
yeah that's in order to keep the news
Christian they have to not even put that
in there so like these pickets and
protests and they're trying to bring
down the walls of Jericho down there but
this infuses this this must an excited
you know you're gonna I'm gonna be your
hero to say if I'm not you're here
already
I'm gonna be your hero because remember
I'm clean and sober yeah so the cops are
there the place is surrounded they've
got the papers filled out they're ready
to take my ass in because I curse a blue
rique obviously but I'm in total control
I'm not like some drunk dude doing it I
know what I'm saying so there's a book
buying and forgetting the guy's name but
it'll come to me but we're it was
written in the 70s and he replaced the
names of all the Supreme Court of all
the curse words in his book he took the
names of Supreme Court justices and put
their names instead of curses
so one Supreme Court judgment was [ __ ]
another Supreme Court justice was [ __ ]
okay uh Gor Gor Vidal I mean the writers
name is gore Vidal so he wrote Myra
Breckinridge if it's a big writer so I'm
gonna stage I said hey look around you
see all these cops
everybody's waiting to take me in for
cursing but I ain't gonna do it
what's the mayor's name I'm gonna do
Miller I said all right
so every time I say Miller every time I
say Miller you you know that I'm sayin
and the crowd says [ __ ] you and when I
say 'mother Miller mother Miller you
know I'm saying [ __ ]
well I went the whole show using the
mayor's name instead of the f-bomb of
that and they are beside themselves and
I'm dancing and I'm like that
hey mother mother for falafel Miller
mama Miller and then everybody's wearing
next shows completely canceled oh really
couldn't get me so then they just
started canceling our shows down south
but at that point did that did that even
magnify things because you know that
controversies that magnify things to
like a level where you're like oh this
has started something awesome or did it
really feel like you were shut like you
had screwed up I didn't think I screwed
up because that was what I did and it
was you know like and was we saw that
this thing was going on with censorship
and these Washington wives PMRC and and
we're going well I don't know to us it
was like business as usual I mean it's
like yeah we're we're crazy
[ __ ] and you know and and
wherever a good time and this is we
never expected twisted [ __ ] sister to
be a household word and and pop stars
but that happened
so that's where it got weird we started
crossing over I'm never getting a family
my favorite pants Akasha goo goo culture
club Duran Duran and Twisted Sister I'm
like whoa I'm like uh-oh just to be in
that list no I knew that was bad I knew
that was anything was going to turn off
our core audience was standing shoulder
to shoulder with some kajagoogoo fan
yeah you know oh I see what you're
saying there so I knew that I knew
things were going south but it was just
this time like - we need more coffee you
think I'm fully caffeinated
I was nearly kicked out of Twisted
Sister for being too caffeinated really
yeah but do you were you born with this
so obviously your idol is pretty high
I'm almost two years sober like angel'
I'll be - you're sober right but you
were born I mean did you know that if
you got into drugs and alcohol that some
that you that something was you were
already lit from the inside yeah but I
had a I had a that come to Jesus moment
right the first time I drank I was 14
and I got so drunk I was on the floor
comatose vomiting and I was just laying
there and people laughing at me like it
scary you know and but I have had oddly
wise moments of my life I've had
incredibly stupid ones too so I'm not
claiming to be you know Yoda or
something yeah but at 14 I just said you
couldn't stop yourself hmm
you didn't just have a drink at the
party you drank until you were crippled
right any recognizes this is my
personality I say so it's like you know
when I drink coffee and I've cut back
but I used to drink three full pots a
day and three big ones from Dunkin
Donuts so I was like I had like an 18
cup of day hive I'd fall asleep on the
couch at night with like my fourth cup
of coffee in my hand I'm not out Ronnie
my teeth come on you might probably like
run my gum BeeZee good so I but I just
recognized saying you just better not go
near drugs
and you knew that about yourself of me
superteen I just said stay away
Wow and I did ever did you or what do
you do you feel like you've had a keen
sense of self management pretty well cuz
that's an early thing to notice at 14
you know I didn't notice that for myself
when I was about 35 36 that I some
things I didn't handle well you know but
to notice that a 14 okay
well I I'm gonna brag for a minute and
then I'm gonna tell you Gosei I'm gonna
say you gonna say well it's got well
unusually unusually focus for ya
and then I'm gonna go and [ __ ] all over
how focused I am so the other thing I
did was I knew I was gonna be famous
uh-huh knew it knew it knew it knew it
and I had this fear I would any girl I
met once I was famous I would never know
if she truly loved me for no well it's
real okay so I'm like it's unlikely
teens that was when I meet a girl
screaming hot Brooklyn Italian girl yeah
I love that but Tommy panitch was 15 I
was 21 it was too late
fam mob princess threatened their
families threatened to kill me on the
first blossom that makes even harder
yeah but she like an element of like
you're cheating death here old school
man they sat was like well I went on saw
Sunday to meet the family I walk in
she's 15 bucket 38 days man I mean and
she's like you know there's a reason why
in medieval times you know girls were
getting knocked up at like 15 I mean I
mean in in Romeo Juliet in the mother
says you're 14 you better find a man
you're gonna be an old maid soon at 14
okay so she's and and I go show up
Sopranos are there Sunday they
threatened to put me in the bottom of a
lake but you showed up
I shall 21 pants so tight you cannot
only tell I'm circumcised you could tell
who did the work all right you go yeah
yeah that's dr. Matt's doctor response
he he cuts up a little bit on an angle
you know so I mean holy [ __ ] and six
inch pink platform shoes hair out here
ain't famous and that's not even hurry
yourself with yourself
I'm not coming like rocking it here hey
what yo what's up you know and they sit
me down see you know whole family's
there dude it was like The Sopranos and
I like their knee knee knee knee knee
knee knee knee I can handle families no
problem yo what's up you know and
they're like yeah yeah I sold like all
the moms and aunts and uncles ill and
all so I'm just sitting there with like
these guerrillas the men the men and
things like all right well you want with
a fifteen-year-old girl I can't tell
them the truth
so I'm sorry I started like I'm laying
down well you know I'm kind of in mature
for my age too already cut the [ __ ] says
you lay one hand on my daughter and this
family will hunt you down to the four
corners of the earth and put you in the
bottom of a lake do you understand what
I'm saying to you now I was wearing skin
tight baby blue pants yeah there's a
dark blue spot this is spread now right
around the crotch area and I remember my
growing
snider because I am gone this girl has
got me just I'm gone mentally I'm
committed and I'm just like yes sir I
understand I know he's saying so um yeah
so that was 42 years ago and um but the
thing was she wanted nothing to do with
me she was repulsed by me she didn't own
a stereo she didn't own a record a tape
she didn't care about music shouldn't
care about rock'n'roll just snuck in on
a dare with some friends into a club and
we're not famous there's seven people
there to see Twisted Sister and I'm
wearing daisy dukes stockings high high
leather boots to the t-shirt says I'm
deep blow me okay that's uh that's
that's that's up that's I and she walks
up to the front and smiles I'm thinking
she digs me Cosette see International
Sign of she wants you yeah she's smiling
because I'm wearing daisy dukes in a
t-shirt says I'm deep blow me and I'm
like seven feet tall I'm a freak
so anyway she was too afraid not to give
me your phone number she gave me your
number anyway I just said if I win this
girl's horde it's gonna be for the right
reasons
and I'll have someone I know loves me
for me Wow and nothing with that all
said no I had nothing she was there I
had everything she was there one of the
lost it all she was there I never
thought
for a minute she was going anywhere when
today 42 years later we're still like I
want a heart we're crazy about each
other and it's all good I seem like a
genius
all right by not by 1988 I made millions
of dollars I wrote every song I'm clean
I'm sober I'm in control I'm running the
show and I completely blow it I blow all
the money I'm broke I got three kids now
I got a wife and I'm riding a bicycle to
a desk job in 1992 answering answering
phones for 200 bucks a week did you
answer them with a little bit of swagger
though tell me you did oh no man how
people were walking in and they go hey
this is it's 92 I just sort of I mean I
mean it's only been a few short years
and I was going hey aren't you and I'm
gonna no look just like him right and
they going holy [ __ ] it's it's uncanny
and I go I know if only there was a way
to make a living doing that I maybe I
should move to Vegas you know I mean so
it was was it Shane like we're now at
that moment are you feeling like I mean
shame shame shame man I am embarrassed I
am humbled I am humiliated and mind you
on the way up I would megalomaniac I was
out of my [ __ ] mind I mean I thought
it was never gonna end so that's why I
didn't stop spending the money yeah I
was sure the next record the next tour
I'm gonna you know I got this and I've
been flash like we buy animals were you
buying like um not we I'm at seven cars
two boats kind of thing and uh you know
in a big house but I wasn't like you
know yeah I'm living like a rock star
yeah and and when things start like
getting a little wobbly the ego that
drove you there that made you believe
when nobody believed that you're gonna
make it well that let you believe that
it's over yeah so and when you start
saying okay let me hold on to the money
and let's see I'll get a smaller house
on and get rid of some of these extra
cars which were the smart move but not
for a rock star man that you know so I
just just ran it completely the ground I
had one year where my tax returns had
zero on it zero dollars I was living off
borrowing money borrowing money
borrowing money but you know just
started scrambling and when it's
everything radio TV movies acting
voiceover look you've been so pro let me
look man you have
yeah I'm looking I'm looking through
some of your history it's like wow this
guy has been a businessman do you ever
feel like because I'm sure like you
where it seem like you've where it worn
a lot of hats I mean you've done it a
lot but it was it was it ever
problematic for you that because
sometimes when you wear a lot of hats
you feel you know you have you you want
to control you want to control things
right you're you're good at controlling
things for yourself was it ever tough to
switch on the music hat and then be the
musician like was it ever I got real
good at splitting foot like before the
crash I was myopic it was on a head
banger I rock this is what I do focus I
wrote all the songs did all the videos
oh by the way just a little side note
Suzette my wife she did all the costumes
hair makeup bone logo so she like became
like sort of this little woman behind
the man like supporting what I dare you
to for but um so I was just I could I
wouldn't you know I wouldn't listen
think even observe anything else except
when I was about and then when the crash
happened
desperation sets in and now I can now
remind you you've got the crash and
grunge the cure for hair metal it's like
you studied a form of medicine and you
spend your life dedicated to research
and finding a cure they finally cure
they go yeah we don't need your services
anymore you're like what yeah we're not
doing that what do you mean we're not
doing who says that to a musician we're
not doing that anymore they literally
said we're not doing that anymore like
this we're not dressing like you singing
like you performing like you acting like
you looking like you we're not doing
anymore and this is all I know how to do
so you did you consider changing your
Stila I tried a little bit I and this is
interesting because it kind of leads to
my new album yeah for the love of metal
but and I have formed a band well I had
a post twisted man called desperado huge
bidding war on it hundreds and hundreds
of thousand dollars spent by me and the
record company and the project gets
shelved due to politics within the label
and and that was that's what the first
bankruptcy then I formed the Banco widow
maker
now grunge is coming in second
Widowmaker album I'm like studying
grunge I'm going okay I gotta get grungy
you know I gotta get grungy and I'm
gonna change my hair and you know and
then like the first review comes out
says sounds like your uncle's trying to
make a modern metal record and they were
right I was no longer like leading the
pack I was trying to imitate imitate the
pack so in 95 ish I said you know what I
guess you know fair enough I had that
fun my times done and I wanted to uh set
radio voiceover always writing movies
all kinds of things and and I stopped
writing and I haven't written music
since then at all until I read me Jamey
Jasta from Hatebreed and he challenges
me to do
a contemporary metal record on his
podcast really yeah yeah Jamie almost
came in here and taped um when he was in
town last time Jamie's Corey
Jamie is great man he's a hard-working
he's a really nice guy great guy he made
the music for the Greyhound break down -
oh yeah he may we had a special episode
we had a Greyhound bus driver come in
and it was our first guest ever actually
only had six guess and going at six I'm
honored yeah Wow we've had some great
man we just had yeah we have we've had
we've had all walks of life actually in
the six and it's it's been really
awesome but yeah it was uh but yeah he
made us some music for that that he made
himself and super sweet guy but I have
this question so when you hit those lows
like when you hit those because man it's
it sound like you just whatever was
inside you when you were born it was
like this rocket ship and you just you
just grabbed on ears just rode it to the
[ __ ] moon yeah but it was incredibly
it's always I've never okay start over D
oh this is live whatever it is you know
dreaming this is all we can edit out I
don't know I always say that start over
day no ozzy osbourne
I quote is saying I was born lucky
and he and Anna love Ozzie and I'm a fan
so please don't get freaked out but I
but I'm but I'm Emperor's New Clothes
guy I'm a guy who's gonna tell you
Amber's got no clothes on because I'm
not gonna splitter and just kiss up for
the sake of kissing up but Ozzy has
stumbled through life
yeah and constantly stumbles like you
know he pisses on the pisses on the
[ __ ] Alamo and it's and it's a it's a
media heyday forum yeah
it's it's it's it's it's image defining
he eats a bites he pulls up supposed to
be alive dove out of his pocket throws
it and it's dead it died in his pocket
he's so wasted his know what to do he's
in front of a whole bunch of executives
he bites a head off legend legend okay
sister
so he anybody else bites the head off a
dove they're homeless homeless and his
career is made solo careers made bit the
head of you know so he um he's just he's
stumbled through life and he's been
picked up carried and he says to himself
he's just he's just been blessed and
lucky yeah and I am NOT I have just been
oppressed and it's just sheer force of
will that I keep just ramming through
there's a documentary on Swiss District
oh we're twisted [ __ ] sister and it's
very highly rated and here if you're not
a fan it's worth watching
cuz the band started in 1973 you all
learned if you learned if you around 84
do the math people that's a long [ __ ]
time to hold it together and refuse to
give up I look back I said [ __ ] if I
knew in advance I would have been a
doctor or something with all those years
yeah but we just refused to give up and
that's just people say wow man you've
had a lot of success it's just because I
keep smashing my head against the wall
until the wall gives up and when you
when you have those moments where you
get into stuff spots is it do you go to
who do you go to for comfort then is
that Suzette is that or is it just that
you or always been self soothing like
how do you because a lot to not have
drugs and alcohol you know a lot of
people when there's crashes and there's
those tough moments those are the first
things they go to so how do you manage
through some of those tougher moments oh
well I'm a narcissist so yeah I mean
that's a started so you know my I'm my
biggest fan God give me long arm so I
could cause they pat myself on the back
but Suzette has also been incredibly
incredibly supportive and and you know
and like you know just said like when
the whole bottom fell out and with his
three kids she had her she's a
professional makeup artist hairdresser
cut she's an MIT graduate and she just
like said all right I'll get a job at a
local hair salon Wow
and she never worked in a hair salon
before but she knew she could get one
and I stayed with the kids and and you
know one weekend she would go out and do
makeup for weddings for a hundred bucks
cash and weeknights I'd fly or cars at
these catering halls I mean once I'm
running through a running from security
in a in a [ __ ] Kate in a parking lot
of catering hall they're chasing me and
I'm running not because I'm afraid to go
in a catering hall jail there's no such
thing but I'm running because I don't
want to recognize me because I'm still
deist not that I look like these Snider
if you find another one let me know and
and I don't want to go deep what are you
doing in a parking lot putting Flyers on
cars in the rain I mean it was it was
that desperate but this is that she just
said go out and do makeup whatever it
took but so she's been like incredibly
supportive but also that person that we
don't want in our lives who will tell us
know when we need to hear no tell us
we're wrong and we nearly broke up at
some point cuz I'm you know eighty five
word no nobody said no to Dee Snider at
85 I'm king of the damn world and she's
still sitting there going yeah now and
I'm going you know what you I no one
says no to me and [ __ ] and you
know and we nearly became apart but then
I got humbled yeah and and I changed my
tune where do you get the bravado that
[ __ ] where does that where do you first
see that because it almost has a little
bit of an amount you know you certainly
seem like your own missile but it
reminds me a little bit of like Dice
Clay but with some more of actual I was
kind of different eyes I was I was kind
of I was doing I was actually doing that
because dice has sort of perfected the
New York bravado yes a thing which is
really weird with dice and and great guy
but he's one of those guys like Marilyn
Manson who became what he liked a
character dice used to be the dice man
was a part of his comedy act I know that
right yeah you know Andrew clay would
get up there and then anybody do
impersonations he's your Travolta to De
Niro does great impressions and then
then he would do the dice man and it
became such a thing he started going out
and doing the dice man but then he
became the dice man I don't even realize
that the Manson was the same way Marilyn
Manson was a performance art thing he's
Brian Warner from Ohio of the marching
band you know and and him and Twiggy
they all had these personas that they
they were living in Florida now putting
on personas and they do this thing on
stage but then all of a sudden he is
Marilyn Manson full time yeah thanks s
himself full time like now now when I
see him at the story he's not even
friendly anymore to people like I mean
he gave a nice like eulogy like speech
at MIT seashore you know the mother of
the comedy store passed away he was
there and he gave this really great
thing on stage but whenever I see him
just around the club he's not it's
almost like he just he does seem like an
angry it's like he became his character
and then his character isn't even doing
that great anymore and he's he's just
this angry character of himself oh god
if I'm feel like I'm beating up and dice
him dice I'm not beating up on you here
but what happens is that character
doesn't necessarily age well right right
home the old version of the character
yeah which is a character unto itself
we've seen in you know in these movies
and stuff but where we've seen that
portrayed these old Brooklyn dudes who
are still you know they're still walking
with the grease back hair and they still
got it and you become instead of like
imitating them you are becoming it yeah
them it's weird yeah it's like and
especially if you get stuck in a
character the character can't go
anywhere really how do you get out of it
writer and and and who does a a
character doesn't really get older and
it must feel like it always has to kind
of stay in this in
in this space where it can exist in this
spot in this almost in this expanse of
time so as a regular person Andrew clay
could get older and adapt and become a
different person but that character does
dice dice can't ever die well though
he's got to stay I and for me Dee Snider
had to grow and mature somehow and
become I hate these I'll use it elder
statesman of rock but one of the things
was you know I started where my hair
pulled back you know I started because I
didn't wanna be recognized but then it
just started like okay that was then
this is now I don't want to be one of
those guys are still walking around with
the fast quickly thinning bouffant yeah
because you see the hair gets it's a
look as luxurious as it was look that
it's thinning and ratty and grays coming
in you know another this dye job man I'm
great as [ __ ] yeah so I mean but I you
know I told my wife I'm practically she
now she said well I'm slowly my wife
says my hair I'm slowly light making it
grayer and grayer so one day you're just
gonna wake up and you can have silver
hair my god down that look grandpa's got
silver long hair now I'm cool so but you
just kind of try an age it's time well
you have to manage it though at least
you're managing and I think some
character some people can get stuck in a
space where it doesn't seem like they do
they did they don't manage it or they
don't accept that things have changed
some you know like you except it seems
like that you are you know like as you
say which is a great term elder states
in Iraq I [ __ ] love that I mean but
you know you're lucky to be one right
you know people when I've got you know
these younger bands or whatever would
look up to me admire you or whatever you
know that's that's blessings yeah yeah
no problem brother
I got nothing but love out here yeah I
love it man I am that man you take me to
that moment where you know you're
putting the Flyers on the cars I can
imagine when I'm you know when I got out
here there was a time where I don't have
a job and so I thought oh I'll clean out
people's refrigerators it's something
that they don't want to do right like
not steal all the food but I'll just
I'll take all the stuff out clean them
really good and then put the stuff back
in it
such a gross thing yeah a cleaning
gutters yes cleaning gutter cleaner you
know chimney cleaners
right this job's people don't want to do
they'll they'll absolutely pay someone
else so I was flying bro it's sneak out
at night and just put fliers like get
out in the below people's apartment
complexes in flower all the car windows
with it and man I remember getting
called and invited over to people's
houses sometimes to clean him out and
the first time I ever did anybody look
like this is the grossest dirty jobs and
that Imraan featured on dirty jobs
cleaning that show dirty jobs yeah
cleaning refrigerators it should be it's
so you want in micro I'll say this about
micro man he he tried to sell that show
for like five years and nobody thought
it was gonna it would be anything he
went everywhere he got like 42 knows and
then finally somebody gave him a yes and
it was a hit yeah he's an amazing man
but yeah just to have that moment and
now at that moment you always knew you
were gonna be a star before that you
said did you still believe that you were
going to be a star or did you how
they'll come back yeah come from I was
giving myself motivational talks you
know I was I was yeah yeah yeah but I as
I sat there and I now now we've got a
shitty little rental house and with
three kids and you know my wife's making
it as nice as possible she's just she's
sewing curtains doing this [ __ ] I mean
she's beautiful man he's a [ __ ]
unbelievable Suzette and and and I'm
working the basement and I'm writing
screenplays and TV shows and and and you
know I'm doing it's all over the city to
invoice over auditions and I got a
little metal show you know just started
doing radio I mean now having over 25
years yeah yet it's not a serious
syndicated out of yeah well how seharris
20 years but I did mornings talk radio
for for three years in Hartford
Connecticut I did nights in Philly I sub
I did Sirius XM for three years so I'm
either but I just started out with a
local metal show 10 to midnight running
the board doing doing doing the ads I'm
on the feel like phone with with the
indie prep guys you know I'm doing the
whole thing 375 an hour you know just
trying to get into radio but I
these moments where you have only you
know you're gonna hear to pull out of
this polling house and the little voice
goes but what if you don't what if this
is it
what if you have just you had your shot
and you [ __ ] it up you know
duh get out of here just push that voice
away because that voice will just
destroy you and you don't let it though
but you didn't let it no I couldn't I
couldn't let let it I just and was it
you at that point that still couldn't
let it was it still like you're you know
um because it sounds like you had a
unique ego one that didn't take you into
some bad places but you really just left
you with it with some extremely strong
drive did but did you at that point
though is it still just that inner that
inner monologue that inner that that ego
that you or is it also like the kids and
stuff like that is any of that affecting
or it's still all Dee Snider
oh no it's it well a lot of people ask
me because you know after the demise of
twisted demise on my music career yeah I
went and did so many things and and was
successful and and you know and brought
myself back yeah you've done something
you've done everything from writing to
hosting to radio to real-time everything
if you watch reality to brought up in on
Broadway
you know I people ask me what like what
drove you I said 10% inspiration
90% desperation Wow and that desperation
of fear of that fall of happening again
still drives me you know if you tell my
wife oh no Dave I said I said yeah so
you know we're entered you know a bit in
retirement mode she's like what and I
said you know well what sort of like
easing up she goes come here she hands
me a legal pad from those big long
yellow ones it's like a foot long she
goes right down the the things you're
working with I filled an entire page
where things I'm working on in different
stages she goes yeah we're retiring here
oh well I mean you know so but but I've
had this terror inside of me cuz it was
such a brutal fall it was so humbling
and it was so ugly and it was so
humiliating and devastating to the ego
to the ego you know that I just I just
started anything if people would say do
you want I go yes
and ago I didn't say what yeah y'all do
it whatever it is I mean literally so
when someone said hey you got a good
voice you - voiceover okay what do I do
yeah you know you know um you should be
a radio uh you can you know you could
this you're that I just I managed like I
said anything if I showed any
inclination to be possibly do it I just
started trying to do it you know did you
feel like a sellout or you feel like a
survivor this is the weird thing so I'm
still trying to keep up still got
fingers in rock and roll
first it's you know was Widowmaker and
already the bottoms falling out so I'm
trying to pull out of it with a new band
so I'm putting on the facade when I go
out of being still be a rock star not
letting people in and let them know the
truth never invited him back to the
house yeah never you know so and and why
wouldn't I believe that he still has
made millions why how who would assume
he blew it Millions last forever as far
as people are killing you he blew
everything so I'm putting on the facade
and not letting people know so when I
walk around the streets I've got you
know baseball hat on and you know hair
is pulled back at that point that people
aren't used to that
pull back hair you know what if people
say hey aren't you gonna no no I'm not
uh and you know my kids know we're
because we Fred you know my wife calls
me Fred the story
hey Fred and he says she knows that to
call me D and it's so I'm hiding my
shame you know so no I'm dolly
I'm definitely it was brutal
yeah I mean you really seem like a
survivor it's so hard I don't think
people realize how hard it is to stay
relevant and working in this business
for a lifetime it's all make you and I
think you're paying me a comment and I
am it's a hostile and it but it's not by
design right I saw an article in a
business magazine that's cited
Dee Snider as branding himself he used
me as an example and I was like well
that's beautiful the way they wrote out
I did and they they sort of broke it
down and analyzed you know like how I'd
put sort of
how thought out this was none of that
was my design I was cold [ __ ] no I'm
just I'm just you know I actually would
slam my name on everything now tell
people just put your name on everything
but even that sort happening by accident
right you know we're wound up being on a
movie I did decider strange land and
then also it was okay well house a Hair
Designers house a hair and so it's
slammed dee snider Dee Snider Dee Snider
but it was never some thought out like
it's so branding right when I write when
I write when you and I started
communicating I said man I don't know if
there's anybody who's branded himself as
the first thing that popped into my head
as well as Dee Center now literally as a
register my name is it's copy written
and is it's a trade dee Snyder brand
that you know but it was net it was not
some brilliant eye I would love to say
yes I knew it all along
ah there's like white noise of screaming
in the darkness and just made it work so
it's not as much masterminding as much
as it is just mining every moment kind
of yeah and just brute dumb force just
forcing it you know just in it's a
square peg just [ __ ] it I can get in the
round hole somehow I'll wear the edges
you know whatever it really is no genius
to it at all honestly do I have talents
I I clearly had son danaiah blade and I
developed them you guys like radio you
know um uh you know I always like radio
I and my book is called shut up is
called shut up and give me the mic I
love radio I love the forum but yes my
agent said look you don't walk off of a
concert stage into a six-figure radio
cake it happened once David Lee Roth
replacing Howard Stern anybody ever to
hear that
remember that did you see that Nana oh
my god it was catastrophic because it is
because you would sing doesn't mean you
can be an air personality yeah there are
two different skills so I had to go and
through the metal show a couple hours a
week and slowly develop that displaces
yeah writing you know I wrote the twist
sister videos but it's me going alright
well the father's yelling at the king
and then the kid turns into Dee Snider
and he kicks his ass
that was me writing the video yeah we've
already called her credits a morning
call the director for developing and
recognizing that it had some kind of
brilliance but then I said well I want
to write these things and I had to study
screenplay writing and I've sold a
number of shows and a number of you know
I've got a number of things now and
movies and things like that I've
developed had things produced but that
was a craft you have to develop you know
it just doesn't come to you now if it
was their point like so it's it's
amazing you you never did you ever
second-guess yourself it doesn't seem
like there's a lot of second-guessing
going on like a lot of people and I find
even when I learn a lot in my own life
that I can be indecisive and I can
really that's one of my faults was like
I'm really second-guess myself that you
didn't you don't really live right there
it doesn't sound like I you know what I
don't know if this applies but it's
where it started um I was 16 not a
popular kid in high school you know it's
just sort of like that weird I was smart
but not smart enough to hang out with
the geniuses
I was freaky but I didn't get high I was
a an A+ student in gym but at long hair
and I wasn't a jock I didn't think the
world was shaped like a football so I
just sort of had no place to hang out
did you realize that you didn't like
realize I was just out there and just
you know did you feel like you were
average um no I knew I wasn't average
right but same time I just knew I didn't
fit in but I found myself sort of just
becoming a Wallflower which is sort of
fading away because I didn't have a fit
in in high school I didn't fit and I'd
remember literally going whoa that ain't
happening that ain't happening and one
of the first things I started like when
people say hey how's it going I would
say excellent I just started like this
positive reinforced myself like I would
always say excellent it's known
excellent everything was excellent
excellent and then people are jealous
like thought they were going what's
what's going on with this dude and it
wasn't true it was just I said I'm gonna
make it a self-fulfilling prophecy if I
say it enough I'll convince myself and
then I'll convince others and it'll
become a reality so to this day how you
doing great if I want the shittiest
the world awesome yeah I'm doing awesome
and and you know they said that they
wants to study that they once tried to
press people they made them smile yeah
and they couldn't stay depressed and it
helped they literally just by forcing
them to smile and say okay just keep
smiling keep smile it couldn't keep the
depression going just can't it
contradicts that signals you're sending
your brain so my brain was like I'm a
[ __ ] zero yeah but if I keep saying
I'm awesome
my brains are you're confused and he's
gonna start believing that this is
actually a true did you strange I wasn't
prepared for this conversation I mean I
obviously sound prepared but it wasn't
no man know what I was walking into
it's okay look I mean I just think it's
super fascinating I mean I mean one of
the most fascinating things I think is
that you have managed to survive in a
crazy world in that and I thought you
had the best branding was the first
thing it's just so funny you say that
I'm like that guy just mastered the art
but to know that so much of of it is
just relentless just like almost like
you say just screaming in the [ __ ]
room yeah until the sound just sticks to
the walls and in that and that but that
could to continue to happen over and
over again and you be in a place now
where you're still positive you're still
creating you're still doing things where
other guys even like our you know like I
would think of you these days and this
is no judgments Andrew Dice Clay but to
me like certain like you know that that
that you almost get to that we that as
long as we stay on a course that we can
not surpass but we can you know we can
stay as healthy and a healthy state
whereas other people might not have the
same state it's fascinating to me it's
interesting man well did you have
moments where it was too dark to other
people did you have moments where you
checked out cuz I mean I feel like there
has to be like another side to like I
had some I had some crash moments and
and is that like you know I would never
I didn't I don't come from I cover an
arrow we didn't talk the word depression
anxiety these weren't
words right you ever you there were
words yeah there weren't words the
people who have earning really apply to
themselves you know peanut allergy I
think this is a phrase that implies I
don't remember anybody bursting into
flames when somebody brought in a
Snickers bar to class but apparently it
happens that's like a dole Desmond broth
you can't hang get the [ __ ] I don't know
so I I um so I never had like you know I
was in a depression or whatever but you
know I remember just moments of just
just yeah just mentally going out wow
the [ __ ] did this happen how did I get
here how did I let this happen and I
thought it was so [ __ ] smart you know
cuz they'd read all the posters about
always rock stars who were drunk and
stoned and didn't know was going on I
had my hands in the pie I was
controlling forever you're sober you
were watching yeah no excuse somehow
that's worse somehow Alisa can't you
know it's those guys ago it wasn't my
fault it was my fault I was a [ __ ]
idiot how does that so that so I really
beat the [ __ ] out of myself honestly
beat the [ __ ] out of me
have you always been really you must
have probably not but have you always
been pretty tough on yourself yeah and I
said anybody who's any good at what they
do is their worst critic you know I am
known for people you know I'm not known
enough for what I do best and that is
front a rock and roll band
there are your few you rock bro I was
watching some clips last night man and I
felt amped up few can hold a candle this
jerk it's what I do
but out of excitement though not of any
no no it was cured Stan man it was no
homo so that's that's coming back a lot
of stuffs coming back fast is it I think
yeah I think I made a fairy joke the
other day and and I said I appalling
mix-up as oh well Oh am i that old guy
who's like
not PC and blurting out like old you
know racist words you know but it is it
not I was great you know and it was with
a couple of gay people there I think
yeah who it it was it was by the same
time yeah is it coming back or you just
like slipping up that's what I wanted I
think people are starting to recognize
that it's more about your intention and
what you mean like Bill burr Chris
D'Elia who's a great comedian and he was
just on here he was saying that bill
burr talks about how he's 50 years old
now and bilborough's looked at as like
the voice of of like the edge like the
edgy voice and Bill burr has said I'm
not supposed to be the edgy voice like
they're supposed to be a 22 year old or
a 23 you know saying there's supposed to
be that next edgy voice how weird is
that
that's not dare he says now cuz you
can't it's like we stop that right this
is just this apply so so much you know
it applies to radio all the great radio
voices are aging aging our personalities
yeah
there's no farm league that's the next
Howard Stern or the neck like they're
not being cultivated for some reason and
I'm wondering if it's that they're not
being cultivated or are the the PC is a
no it's too general a term but you
understand I'm saying that that that
we're cleaning everything up all the
rough edges everybody's a winner and
everybody you know I saw I saw Chris
Rock and a bunch of other comedians you
may have seen it talking and they said
when they stop bullying that's the end
of comedy that basically all the great
comedians were bullied we're bullied you
know and and that it and and bullying
forces creativity yeah rock stars and
unpopular kids it's those of the people
who become it's never it's rarely the
Matthew McConaughey's of the world are
like there's not even he's just a
one-off yeah a one of like I was the
most popular guy in school handsomest I
was an Aries great I was in the I was in
the fraternity and it turns out I'm an
Academy award-winning actor
go figure day one you know that that's
those don't happen everybody else has
got mental scores they're damaged and
that's how we worked on our art either
literally art or music or comedy or
whatever it comes from being damaged
yeah I had to find I remember being or
is are we cleaning everything up so much
and making it so safe that the young
edgy bill Birds the 20-somethings aren't
there anymore right you know what's
weird is that in my generation it's us
that are getting offended it's not our
parents back in the day used to be the
parents that we're getting offended like
they I don't want my kids
Wow what a statement and what a
statement so truly that is so my
daughter's she gets so pissed off 21
she's a feminist
head banger she's a cool as [ __ ] yeah
she really is but boy she schools us
like we say one missed word one date you
know dated not my what my wife said
[ __ ] the other day yeah in my daughter
she hangs she sees the club scene and
she hangs with the boys yeah and she
said you know mom I'm not gonna take
your head off this time but I forgetting
the right terminology it's trans you
know is that what it was plural how do
you say is it transits multiple trans
it's so crazy yeah but yeah how do we
like yeah I remember the thing that
probably ended up it was years of like
toiling around the playground and
thinking that people hated me or I was
less than or something or like you know
or just feel being made photo just you
know it was just it was your back
against the wall made you [ __ ] sprout
whatever was gonna come out of your
chest you know and it's it's a sad
reality but it's true
I mean I'm it can't be true my dad is is
is 87 he the guy in the videos
that's my dad literally what do you want
to do with your life that's my dad
screaming at me that was my that whole
video was based on my home life okay and
he was a cop that you know
hard-ass unemotional [ __ ] brutal and
I'm writing a Father's Day card out I'm
going thank you I did I'm going like cuz
he actually at my mom's funeral
he mentioned in his eulogy to as my mom
said and maybe I was a little too tough
on D and I mean literally apologized in
the eulogy I felt bad for him that he
was like reeve reflecting but as I was
sitting there going am I happy with the
man I am yeah and why am i the man I am
why am i tough why did I survive why did
I you know fight the way I fought
because he was so [ __ ] tough on me
yeah and I'm like thank you I don't
regret it I do it again and I can't
believe I wrote that cuz I hated that
[ __ ] he was a definition we're
not gonna take it was him you know all
my songs were him you piece you [ __ ]
bust my balls I'm gonna show you
[ __ ] and I'm gonna look at dad
and thank you for making me the man I am
but I mean it I can't believe I'm
looking back going if they didn't do
that if he was at everybody's number one
dad and your you know your great son you
know me nothing I wouldn't I
yeah what would you be well I did have a
discussion with him once because he
tried to take credit for my career many
years ago he said if I wasn't so tough
on you this before I realize you
wouldn't be the success you are I said
yeah how you know it wouldn't be happier
as a well-adjusted accountant just
sitting in my cubicle crunching numbers
and smiling you know no emotional scars
nothing yeah but um it's weird about you
given the choice okay Alison I'm taking
the show woman no I got it so you said
you weren't that you your money and you
got your comedy but now I don't think I
develop that that that fire if like if
the if I don't have any turmoil if
nothing you know like we didn't have any
money to go play sport like I couldn't
go play sports cuz my mom was like if
you get hurt you're gonna be that kid
that's hurt you know you're gonna be
that you know if you find it you break
your collarbone you're gonna be that kid
whose shirt doesn't fit
and so then I just pictured myself
always so but it was just like there was
something I couldn't over sports because
they have money yeah like like like we
did have money a family there was no
allowance you wanted any any money in
the pocket you had to go do sell
newspapers ammo along so kids who went
out for sports they had an allowance
yeah they were oh they were living high
on the hog yeah I remember they come to
yeah they had their nice you know you
just sport socks or whatever and I was
like man I guess anything about the
broken thing cuz my dad was a cop so he
had that that civil servant like medical
program so we'd be fixed I love it we
knew we'd be fixed right thanks they
call it back ya know but I just think
it's fast did you guys uh did you you
know relating him farah naaz farida him
did you ever do a bunim-murray show no
oh I thought I remember they did this
show about rock wives a while back oh
wait yeah is that we weren't rock wise
who's the person farah naaz was this
lady's name I don't remember that name
but we we do we were definitely rock
star wives thing yeah I thought I
remembered actually at one point meeting
a group of the ladies came out to a
comedy show I think or they did stand-up
comedy so I remember meeting them one
time oh just kind of crazy anyway um
what about this so outside a completely
outside a political stuff you worked
without you were on apprentice with
Donald Trump once I did two and a half
seasons pretty much on that show and I'm
not trying to get anything political I'm
just I was gonna ask you what do you
what did you think about Bert what do
you think about Donald just in the show
space like what do you think she was
like you know I've been asked about this
a lot because after doing as on the end
of the finale of the John Rich yeah yeah
John Ratey want for the next year then I
came in for the all-stars and during the
course of that time I became friendly
with with the Trump's with Lanka so hot
is she hotter person with the kids yeah
beautiful beautiful but there but beyond
that it's cool people
gracious people charitable people and so
we became you know we became friendly
and it was cool but you know I said
people
the rules of socializing don't talk
about sports don't talk about religion
don't talk about politics yeah which we
didn't I mean I have one of my best
friends I worry ankiet he wears a Boston
had we've never mentioned our hats
because he's one of my best friends
the day that I say uh he mentions my hat
we're over right we are [ __ ] over
because that's oil in water right there
ain't mixing so but we never to mention
hats we wear our hats I love that
everything's fine
so I love I you know I got along great
with the Trump's then and I say in
people can you understand what I'm
saying to you how do you be friends with
somebody and not know what their
political I know religion they were I
know their political affiliations with
teams they like yes socialized then all
of a sudden he becomes on the political
stage and whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm not
down with that I'm not down with that
I'm not down with that right so did he
said the same thing the other day and he
said the same thing you know that yeah I
was friends we were friends but when you
all of a sudden you realize that you you
where you stand differs so much yeah the
relationship suffers and nothing I say
if people is you know I mean you
befriend somebody how do you forget you
name like one friend one of your friends
do that you would say yeah I support him
as president of the United States none
none zero I don't know what am I crazy
for one friend here including Donald
Trump not one why we know them and they
know us they know [ __ ] that if they
don't nobody wants to know it's an
outdated job almost it really is it like
they get $500,000 a year yeah and there
really aren't in control
nah yeah there's a lot of chatter but
ultimately they're not I wonder if it's
fun I wonder if he has fun doing it
that's what I hear I don't have this
gonna be winding a blabbermouth or so
but I know you know I know like I said I
know I had fun I have friends at are
friends with him yeah and I think that
did not really join it yeah not it's not
the way he lived
I mean look I've been to
his house it was awesome huh yeah he's
stepped he's slumming at the way he
stepped down I've been on the Trump jet
he's slumming on Air Force One salamat
there's no gold anything on Air Force
One it's nothing but gold and marble
pink marble and gold and in mahogany
okay that's I mean so he is that's why
that's why funk whatever his wife is
she's a Milani as it stays in New York
I don't listen I'm not you the Lincoln
Bedroom you tell oniel colonial colonial
anymore so I mean so I think he's he but
I do believe he believes he's doing a
job in I'm sorry done a service yeah and
you know when he believes in the service
he's doing who's what leave that to yeah
that's a great question
that's a great question anybody who
would you even put in there like I can't
even think of a couple like I almost
feel like like I'm friends with Howie
Mandel almost like Howie Mandel well
maybe we would possibly good but cuz
that for the you know for the OCD and I
can't get any germs on me that's a
little bit you know that speaks volumes
but he would fit yeah but just to see
him fist bumping other world hears I
think would be pretty cool but otherwise
you're right
we're eight the fact that we don't also
recognize sometimes that we are all like
broken
unperfect individuals and see and this
is why I say I believe that that kids
are young people and my everybody looks
up to rock stars because they and
comedians we wear our hearts on our
sleeves yeah
there's no secret yeah people's I
usually run for office I said well a no
be if I did
yeah there's pictures of me wearing
lingerie yep I shall give them to you
there I mean is those secrets
I've got no secrets and isn't honesty to
that yeah that you don't see in any
other job honestly of comedians the
honesty of musicians and actors to an
extent you know every other in the arts
were honest outside they're hiding all
that [ __ ] yeah well it's gotten so much
more control I think it's become the
arts
become such a business and you may have
noticed as well with music like that
there's almost two worlds you can get in
you can get into some of the mainstream
stuff that's so good that's more control
because there's more advertising dollars
and stuff over there
or you can also you can kind of stay in
this middle lane between the fringe and
mainstream where it's like everything's
still great there's still like
advertising money and people coming on
board but you can I feel like you can
hold on to a little bit more of your
beliefs and just and speak your mind a
little bit more and I think you see that
a lot with podcasts like podcasts are
booming today like it's I mean Joe Rogan
is like the tonight it's like you go on
Joe Rogan it's like I felt like I'd gone
to the moon when I got a text from Joe
Rogan one night and he said come on the
podcast brother I felt like I just got
an approach by Johnny Carson like it was
like you know it's just because there's
more freedom show I thought you were a
fan I've interviewed you on my radio
shows I think for you out of podcast
I thought clearly remember you being a
fan come on brother I got a new album
coming out I love it let's start very
smart very smart very interesting and
that is an interesting thing though we
could all over the [ __ ] place is your
show not mine
no look it says look man I'm just a you
know I admire you no really I'm just
saying what about the it's what's the
dance that we have to do in the with the
political landscape the way it is trying
you know John Rich said it best John
Rich who's a very right wing right wing
and Trump as from the players
integration and inauguration and John
said he said to him listen I want
everybody to buy my records yeah
even the even though he's gun toting
cowboy this that the other thing you
know righty-tighty he still isn't gonna
go doesn't want to take that make that
distinction yeah so clear right I'm
choosing sides right you know and I know
Rogen everybody we got to kind of walk a
line because it's so severe people get
really [ __ ] upset when you pick a
side do you feel like it's as severe as
the news makes it out to be and the
media makes it out to be maybe it is
people are people are kind of a divided
more than ever okay Christmas at the
Snider house my mother
she recipes is in the hospital dying we
have the family Christmas and over
politics
it literally my big family my big dumb
family is thrown
it's nearly throwing down well fit it
became close to fisticuffs at the family
Christmas with our children or
grandchildren yeah all around great
grandchildren there's 50 of us now
moms on life support and it's just about
it's just about erupted Wow people had
to be pulled out of the room was it um
into your mother passed away yeah she
did it what I'm really ugly brutal long
yeah hit by it was 85 like this vibrant
art teacher artist you know active in
the community drove a car I mean she was
just 100% yeah no medical history no
meds no I used to say mom I'm look at
you and I'm thinking alright man
I think she'll be pretty genetically if
I got your [ __ ] I'm gonna be pretty cool
and hit by car brain damaged vegetable
two months life support pretty much life
support and then died and it was yeah
for between Halloween and she died on
January 2nd it was it was ugly but the
point is you know I've never gonna aw a
moment here people you know it was
tragic was it but that's the thing is
it's just that's life you know that's
one thing it makes you say is [ __ ] you
have no one that you know the fickle
finger of fate is gonna gonna get you
come looking for you yeah it's just
was she pretty proud do you think your
mom was real proud of you not a big fan
nothing she had her moments so she was
proud you know when I was on Broadway
cuz they were like it's here someone
there's somebody I've been taking at the
picture to stand in front of the marquee
the starring Dee Snider Rock of Ages
they like that when Celine Dion recorded
a Christmas song I wrote my wife and it
was just like a legit Christmas song she
was very proud of that but you know when
I've got so Fred I'm so proud of we're
not gonna take it in hindsight when you
look back on that
like as you as you wrote music and you
had hits and you did you then start to
feel pressure to write hits and not
write right from like a place of you
know absolutely you know the answer of
you absolutely you just and is it human
nature you think yeah well we're also
because it's like it's like when you're
an executive you you're struggling in
the corporate world and you get that you
get you working and you you know and you
just taking chances you're coming up
with ideas and suddenly like you get the
winter idea and they give you the corner
office the big raise the view and all
the sudden you're going yeah I don't
want this to end
now you starting to second-guess how now
I gotta stay here how'd I do that I
remember sitting poolside the big house
the cars the boats I'm sitting poolside
and I'm trying to write the next song
about teen angst and literally I go hey
I got nothing I mean you know vewy two
years earlier we're not gonna take it
[ __ ] and now I'm like mmm no I'm
definitely taking this and I'm
definitely this is this is awesome this
is awesome
I don't want this to ever stop so now
like panicking you know huh and now
you're thinking about it yeah you know
and that's you've lost that you know by
almost called stay hungry but you it's
hard not to lose that that's what I love
about new bands my kids are all
headbangers they take me out to the
shows and they've got that I would say
the most dangerous person in the room is
the one with nothing to lose nothing
they just kill me you know so and that's
you see these bands and they're hungry
they got no record sales they got
nothing but passion and hard and it's
just out there thing [ __ ] you I'm rockin
and now I just feed off that like a
vampire it's like I wanna I don't like
to listen I mean I love the pass but I
just don't want to smell my knees
listening to old bands and old artists
and old music give me some new [ __ ] I
got it like a vampire I want to feed off
that that energy that [ __ ] you yeah we
just put in the whole show
it started with [ __ ] you and it's
[ __ ] you well I want to know about your
new album that man hit me with a little
bit of information about our your new
project for the love of metal I thought
my a and 95 I stopped writing new songs
because I said it my times done it's
it's a different era a different age let
them do their other people have the
limelight and I just thought I was and
then I put out now last year a
mainstream rock record that didn't work
I'm like you know what I'm doing great
you know fine I'm on the Jamey Jasta
podcast Johnson says I've got a
challenge for you do a contemporary
metal record when I stayed up who's
producing Syd I will I said and who's
writing the songs cuz dude every time I
write a song it's like another one I
can't take it
so a guy says I'm like you studied in
ancient philosophy you know and he goes
D your Dee Snider man you're an icon
everybody's gonna want to write I said
well let's do it so with no budget no
recruit record deal nothing we just
start going to the studio and creating
and and we do the first song as I call
[ __ ] and then I'm going home [ __ ] this
thing's this is cool and and they're and
they're going [ __ ] this is better than
we thought was gonna be you know
contemporary metal but with an iconic
rock voice just roaring I'm just like I
could I can just click in the zone
feeling so weird and then all of a
sudden phone Jaime's phones blowing up
people from Lamb of God disturb
Killswitch Engage you know they're
they're like these record man we got so
we got music
so everybody's Howard Jones is in there
just singing and and all these people
and it says and we've got no money we're
just doing it love for love we're doing
it with a [ __ ] yeah we're doing
inspiration we're having fun and I'm
loving it they're loving working with me
I'm loving just like I told you and it's
I'm a vampire want a new blood I want
that new energy so then we can finish
the record and is a bidding war from
them from all the major metal whose
metal labels everybody wants it
holy [ __ ] this is like really happening
so before we had the bidding war and all
that Jamie comes in goes I got the title
for the record for the love of metal and
I'm like that's it
cuz this is what it's been and you knew
it right then when he said it well
because that's what it was what it was
no money there was no people with spare
time coming in it was just passion
it was just pure passion people are
having a good time doing it
singing you know angry and hostile but
they say that's a beauty of metal is you
afterwards you feel good you see that
study that said head bangers metalheads
work better adjusted people than adults
emotionally oh yeah totally see there's
a major study and then now I just didn't
want interview with psychology today
they're doing a big piece because now
they're know what's going on and I said
well I could've told you that a long
time ago because it it's it's a release
for all the dark emotions yeah hate fear
depression anxiety of you know broken
hearts whatever whatever the dark
emotions Dark Arts
that's heavy metals that's that's our
bread and butter yeah but we feel better
after you get out of the pit and you're
laughing yeah you know I sang a song a
song on the record it's called roll over
you and it's justice it's [ __ ] you from
beginning to end the course is literally
a group singing wave [ __ ] despise you
know that got no heart on your soul
we [ __ ] despise you and so I get that
into the song and the and I just get to
the end and not anything and as a so
[ __ ] yeah and then I just start laughing
and the laugh is on the record and we go
how are you laughing and to seeing such
an angry song I said I'm laughing
because I sang such an angry song and
and and I feel better because I let that
out somebody this morning said to me you
know what maybe was just wake up the
morning going [ __ ] you and then like and
then start the day like start with a
[ __ ] you just get that out of the way
yeah and then say okay you know what
feel better already get it off your
chest
[ __ ] you man I went skydiving recently D
in uh everyone's had Evan know I've
watched my wife trip a dude and it was
the first time in a long time
when I was in the air I could just
scream bro and now you can't do that in
LA without your neighbors calling if
somebody's gonna get upset like ice crit
bro and I screamed for like 40 I'll just
let it Adam and I never felt so relieved
ride a motorcycle it's got that feature
really yeah when you're riding in the
wind and you're blasting down you can
sing full voice you nobody can hear you
is either bikes drowning you out and
you're like just let it run other than
people seeing a man's mouth is like a
[ __ ] cavern still rock is still
rockin day he's just losing his [ __ ] on
the cycle when does uh when can we check
it out and we can uh for the love of
rock for the love of metal society
that's all right the circle of metal
the first single just came out um it's
it's called
tomorrow's no concern it's I mean it
went to metal radio it's heaviest yeah
so that's out now to videos I got I am
the hurricane coming out in a couple
weeks you know and then I've got a
couple videos coming out a couple we set
to that and the album the full album
gets released July 27 for the love of
metal pre-orders are going on now and so
far I haven't been this pumped about
something a long time and initial
reactions of people hearing it responses
well 50 percent is like I was not ready
for that like Dee Snider full-on 63
raging on the nu metal [ __ ] not in you
know any w nu metal [ __ ] me was not
ready for that how cool and I'm like you
know what I love that I love surprising
people and I love you know just you know
I didn't record is Broadway why because
I wanted to and I'm singing with Patti
LuPone and Bebe Neuwirth rocked out
Broadway classics and and my manager
goes who's gonna buy this I said
probably nobody but I wanted to do it I
just I just you know and people like
what the [ __ ] is Dee doing I don't know
just keep him guessing man [ __ ] like
you're there yeah like you're here just
keep some guessing you think your
opening man their hair
what's going over your hair or that
gender-neutral style yeah yeah it's just
like yeah is it is it mullet and I'm not
sure yeah I don't even know I mean
people made fun of what I didn't like
was people made fun of like you know
people where I was from it was like oh
they don't accept people of people are
gender neutral you know there was always
this thing like the news would go find
some weirdo in Kentucky you know it
doesn't want to build a bathroom well of
course he doesn't want to there's no you
know nobody everybody he knows it uses
one of the other you know he can't get
the permit he probably needed the money
for it so to bother the dude about
building a [ __ ] extra restroom but
anyhow I'm like we've been supporting
gender-neutral like people in my
neighborhood have had women's hair the
men have had him since I was born bro so
you gonna say will you want to go wear a
woman's hair cut for a month I do I
think it's a byproduct of the invention
of the flow be without the flow be the
thing that sucks vacuums are here and
cuts it for you yeah it's like yeah
technically it works yeah well I'm not
what the [ __ ] coming out on the other
side man I think it makes a metaphor you
know oh I got a gift too for me today
this is from our sponsor Ridge wallet
and they have this really cool man
I like it they do this it's a tote bag
it's black it'll fit you in then one of
these Ridge wallets that I use to you
can take one thank you it's basically a
new wallet they made it's like a front
wallet so it's like you know you keep
all your credit cards or whatever if you
want can't carry that condom around
anymore because still rock you know yeah
but yeah there you go so it's just a new
ID huh yeah they're pretty cool yeah I
like it that's very cool thank you rich
no yeah no rich and thank you uh dude
I'd love to have you come back sometime
and just think about other stuff I wanna
I'd love to think about I got a place in
the area that was kind of weird as good
as we live in Belize we built a house on
the hold really yeah right on the water
is like I just like you know I gotta get
on the safe side of the wall did you owe
that to your wife in a certain form
you're like okay I gotta get we owed it
to each other
yeah we just cuz people talk and I'm
talking to you people out there but you
know we all we we all talk
one day we're gonna yeah one day we're
gonna get that motor home and go travel
around one day we're gonna buy a
sailboat and we're gonna sail one day
we're gonna look but most people never
pull the trigger is it scary it's a
commitment it's it's in a lot of time it
involves a big move it means leaving
behind your connections and all stuff
like that and a lot most people don't
pull the trigger and we got that point
we always said well talked about want to
build a house down the Caribbean on the
beach and then the kids all moved out
and we're like well are we gonna be
those people who talked about it
all those people who did it Wow I
remember my uncle my father's brother
you know here we said well is that I had
retired was another cop I retire I'm
moving to Virginia I'm getting a farm
and he said that his entire life and
then he retired he goes okay I'm moving
I'm going to get in a farm my father
goes where you going
and we said I told you I'm getting a
farm yeah but nobody does it I mean you
talk about getting the farm you don't
actually buy the farm yeah but I want to
be one of the people that did it so we
built the house down there we lived down
there most of the time but we keep an
apartment here that we can because we
got our kids and our grandkids out here
so and how has it been how it now you
know having done that as it been as
rewarding as you expected as if you have
you felt separate have you felt
alienating and what does it been like
felt feel like I'm cheating death really
I feel I feel like it's I've actually
feels so heaven like that going like if
they if I one day God walked in and goes
by the way you're actually dead I'm go
oh [ __ ] oh well well yeah this works
speech I get a morning I don't watch the
news every we have that cable and
everything yes it under my palapa
drinking my coffee looking at the ocean
watch the Sun come up and going this is
cool this is cool so yeah so it's it's
not a disappointment on any level is it
been hard to relax a little bit come
even you're you know you're a scrapper
you're a guy who's you know you you
you've you know is it hard to relax
my wife would say yes um yes and no
because I focus that's when I do a lot
of writing I've been doing a lot of
writing book writing a screenplay
writing you know I wrote a musical and
so I do a lot of writing and they're
just I just I love it it's down into my
palapa by the beach and I got great
internet too and I just just on my
computer and just create get creative so
I am producing on another layer creator
yeah is it in do you think that
creativity obviously it's it's you know
it's a blessing but there's it there's
times probably when it's also it's it's
it's too much it's it's a curse kind of
in a way because it's you can't stop it
got me here from friggin days know what
I mean I'm having a great time
it's like it's like I don't want I don't
necessarily want to end this
conversation
ya know well it's one of the questions I
had originally written down it was like
I prefer you ask me that enlightenment
can be hectic you asked me about okay
this is I'm I trained myself kind of am
like I am kind of like Yoda ish but I
trained it a like I said I was myopic
now I do so many things my son who's a
filmmaker he says dad it blows my mind
I'll watch you change from job to job to
job while you're sitting there and and
you just switch gears but that was a
train I had to train myself literally
mentally I'm changing hats yeah so I'm
going from okay I'm working on new music
oh now I'm working on a screenplay oh
now I'm doing a voiceover gig no I have
to do my radio show I just mentally I am
actually changing hats and I've gotten
really good at it
it was more of honest necessity yeah
yeah it was in the sense of saying were
you now the other thing was I had the
problem where the creativity just came
out like like it just was just pouring
out and I couldn't stop it but I
couldn't document it so it was I
wouldn't remember the song I was
thinking about because they don't have
like photo photogenic photogenic
photographic memory photos out of a
photogenic memory is it doesn't look
good in pictures but I so I trained
myself
- shut the faucet off literally and this
is gonna make people some people are
gonna be like you scumbag I and I were
just turning on when I was ready so case
in point stay hungry album the biggest
album I ever did my wife was going to
the store grocery shopping my son was
just born asleep in the crack in the
crib in our studio apartment and my wife
said I'm going to stores I'll be back in
you know in about an hour I said okay
man she left the same I'm able do a
little writing pulled out my song title
list which is what I work off of and I
wrote the stay hungry album the biggest
out of my career in 45 minutes
I wrote the guts of I wanna rock we're
not gonna take it the price all of these
songs the entire record in 45 minutes
and then turn the faucet off stop
thinking about creativity and then I
know now I have to write the words I had
to help cuz I wrote a I wrote actually
wrote probably 40 ideas but in those 40
ideas that I just just vomited out
sorted through them and those songs were
all in the vomit it's clear that peas
and carrot self fit and wiped off the
goo and polished him out but so I just
put the end I was trained trained myself
to turn the faucet off because otherwise
it just and then it becomes a
frustration yes now you can't get the
ideas down you forgot that joke and oh
my god had a great idea [ __ ] what was
that thing again and it never as funny
as when you first thought of it even if
you're saying that I'm thinking you know
I have to start to think it just times
when I control any times when I don't in
times when I say set myself aside and
say hey this is a great time to sit down
right now and write and really focus on
that um yeah and let that vomit happen
man I gotta go I got in the bathroom
I've got
shooting two videos tomorrow it's two
videos you know he's like know it and
this acted a hundreds of thousands of
dollars it was the making making a movie
yeah now I was like 5 grand apiece yeah
you go with it but you can do it all you
do yeah but it's also the money's just
not there in the business anymore right
but it's but it can be I find in your
own pocket because you can create it
yourself and you know
but dude uh thank you so much to you for
coming in man we really appreciate it
and we'll share out the new album and
we'll we'll share out the videos as soon
as they pop up anything we can you know
let me know when you're when you're
performing again local yeah justjust
just email me text whatever I know no I
really enjoy you yeah man watching your
show to see these shows and my son was a
compared one point as a comedian then he
started to his mental health got
improved then he stopped uh
hey you guys see we stopped being manic
depressed there's an affliction yeah he
got he was one of Caroline's like summer
pics
oh nice in New York in New York she gave
his own show and and you know she does
that she does this the pics you know and
yeah he picked them so he was he was
slogging it out and he ended on a high
note that was like his last one he met a
girl start feeling better emotionally
help and he says you know what it's just
so brutal yeah being a stand-up and I
and I and I've been friends with cult
wait and Kennison and so many comedians
and I just got such respect for them for
the work you know with a rock band
you got a gang up there you got the
noise okay all the people that you
always see them saying you suck you guys
look there were you dick in your hand
man
well nobody goes you suck it's like
there's no ignoring it
yeah you can't look at your drunk you
can't hear you you know it's just right
there has to be dealt with in some
capacity you know and you guys have the
most dangerous job thanks man yeah Mike
back to Mike Rowe but man sheer will I
love it dude you're you're you're an
inspiration man and I love your sheer
will your just tenacity to [ __ ]
achieve through survival man it's it's
cool man and I admire it and thanks you
ever die dude I'm gonna drink your blood
right of your body please I'll take a
couple pints and Dee Snider I just wanna
I just wish I could just stick a flash
drive or something just right in the
base of my spice Mike you know you know
medulla oblongata right there and just
download the [ __ ] with so much
information to waste here take it run
with it man yeah wrong with it somebody
run with it I love that
we'll see you in the future d great
being on this past weekend with the ovum
yeah thank you
[Music]
a little time for me to set that parking
brake
oh ma
[Music]